um and so I was telling a friend of mine
because because he was like walking
ahead of the group it's like we ran up
and hey dude I had this revelation like
I want a woman somebody I can grow with
some me I could build a life with and in
the middle of telling him this somebody
like wanted to ask him a question like
excuse me I have a graham like how the
[ __ ] is interrupting me and then middle
of me telling that I want to meet my son
oh [ __ ] she's hot
I miss mine who is my wife [ __ ]
rom-com girl I that [ __ ] happens in the
movie me cutes he's talking about it
excuse me right and then that's the one
I just find that happens in everything
about I just talk about it you know what
it's what happened let me say so so you
met her and then what happened and then
is this too personal I I really look I'm
really I don't know I used to I loved it
yeah I want to know yeah so we met and
then it was like super and if you really
want it like it's like super intense we
bought in a very deep level we're like
in Israel were going to spiritual
science for like neither one of the
women I married ever watched nice yeah
and so yeah so we were we just like
bonded really deep really and then it
was the one they just it was so it was
different than like most relationships
and that we both knew what this could be
right away and so we were like let's not
burn out so we actually actively had to
be like okay we're not gonna talk on the
phone for four hours a day every day we
actually like did these like periods of
like restriction where we didn't talk
for like a week just because it was like
I had [ __ ] to figure out intern Amy and
the guy had to pull my life together I'd
have pulled my career together she was
she was going places this girl is smart
and like in that time period this is in
your 30s yes so we're talking after
Dawson's Creek yeah
who's this you did an CSI kind of a show
right that was later that was after you
met her you said there was a was there a
period what you weren't working yes yeah
now we all go through that oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's Petersburg wasn't
working this period was like what can I
do there piers where I did bad TV movies
just to like make a little coin yeah I
mean which listen there are a lot of
people struggling a lot harder than a
Christmas movie up in Vancouver yeah you
know to make ends meet but um yeah we
when you did stuff like that did it
depress you I at the time he was kind of
my way out of depression it was almost
like therapeutic like you know what and
what I learned from those jobs is like
if I can't show up to set and be happy
to be on a set be happy to be or any
money and like be happy to just be
adding value yeah on a movie that I wish
nobody will see then how am I ever gonna
be able to handle being on a set on
something I'm proud of because really it
shouldn't like what people think of the
end product or how impressed there with
you should matter absolutely not at all
when you're on that set yeah and so I
took it as like a real boot camp in just
learning to [ __ ] assassinate my own
ego and get the [ __ ] over myself
and just show up and act I you're what
you're about to make me cry and be happy
doing it yeah that's exactly what you
need to learn Bob something man yes
what the [ __ ] I mean you nailed it on
the [ __ ] button there man it's like I
had a I had need more gratitude in my
life man that's what it is assassinate
the ego Bobby I had to assassinate the
ego you know and whatever he said I'll
rewind it and yeah yeah and tape like
mantra
[Music]